there are many moments in this movie
that I love but there's one in
particular that got me thinking about
just the power and importance of spot-on
line delivery and specifically it's when
you tell vanellope I'll miss you so when
you're in the sound booth doing a scene
like that
you just do it a whole bunch of times
and then keep your fingers crossed they
pick that take or do you all just know
it well yeah that's an interesting
interesting question because I do my job
is kind of to provide raw materials you
know and then they're refined later by
the animating team and by rich and Phil
the directors so I mean to answer your
question about how you how you I think
it's I think it is kind of obvious to
everyone in the room I just do as many
takes as I can until I feel like okay I
I did the best I could do with that I
did it the most honest way I could do it
that's really usually what I'm chasing
it's like I really you know something
without artifice like a real direct
because when you're when you're doing
voiceover for animation like you're
conveying everything through your voice
so you have to really plug in and I
think what made that line really work to
tell you the truth Perry is that Sara
and I really love each other you know
and when I look into Sara's eyes and
it's a real thing it's not just me
pretending it's like me saying to Sara
I'm gonna miss you you know like it's
it's a real thing you feel it it's the
heart of this movie and now I feel like
that heart grew because of gal's
character too and the parallels between
those two relations yeah definitely it's
cool that girls characters Schenck
is actually she's like my competition
for a friendship you know but it's
really cool that she's just not she
doesn't say like oh get rid of that guy
she's like be yourself you know if you
want to be my friend you can be my
friend too I think that was a really
cool thing and she did an amazing job
there's so much positivity in this movie
and it's a movie about the internet and
I feel like whenever we talk about the
Internet it usually isn't a negative
light oh we all have to disconnect but
this had a different feel to it so kind
of to continue that I was wondering what
do you do on the internet that truly
brightens your day
on the internet that brightens my day
well I read a lot of news on the
Internet and that doesn't always
brighten my day I suppose like reaching
out to friends is really that's I mean I
don't use social media and I don't
interact with strangers on the Internet
but what I do use the internet for is
checking in every day with a group of
friends I used to back in the day I
spend an hour on the telephone calling
all different friends how you doing
what's going on those check-in calls now
it's a check-in text you know yeah which
people give a lot of flack for that but
you can communicate more with people
with texts I think than you can by by
talking on the phone I can used to do so
yeah that's what I use the internet for
is to reach out and stay in touch with
you think I'm right there with you
because my Nana got Facebook she will
probably watch this interview when I
post it otherwise she would never
Thank You Sona
[Music]
you
[Music]